foreign
there are numerous such tasks in daily
life that are totally disrupted when
their order is changed for example in
language the sequence of word defines
their meaning in Time series data times
defines the occurrence of event and in
genomic sequence data e-sequence has a
different meaning there are numerous
examples of this where the sequence data
influence the event itself if you want
to use such data for any useful output
we need a Network that has prior
knowledge of the input to fully
interrupt it thus thus recurrent neural
network comes into play RNN so hello
everyone I am mayank and welcome to
Simply learn today we will take you
through a hands of lab demo of how we
can use RNN model for sentiment analysis
in machine learning
so let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a tech geek or a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply run
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will discuss what RNN
model is moving ahead we will see why
should we use RNN after that we will see
how does RNN work the current neural
network after covering these topics we
will move forward and see types of RNA
recurrent neural network and
applications of Arduino at the end we
will do a hands of live demo of
sentiment analysis using RNA in fact
study says there will be more than 2.3
million jobs opening in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by 2023 but you can beat the
curve with a professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning
co-sponsored by Purdue University and
IBM and that is designed after simply
learns intense bootcamp learning model
Ai and ml certification course so this
course covers tools and techniques like
python tensorflow Keras nltk and many
more along with industry projects like
social media Twitter zomato delivery
service provider Uber transportation
service provider and many more Amazing
projects so choosing this course can you
get hired by renowned companies like
Google Amazon LinkedIn and Adobe and an
average salary hike of 70 percent so
what are you waiting for join the AI and
ml professional certificate program and
Excel your career in Ai and machine
learning so the link is in description
box below don't forget to check it out
so before starting let us have a simple
question to brush our knowledge so
question is what are the application of
RNN okay NLP
time series image captioning and all of
the above please answer in the comment
section below and we will update the
correct answer in the pin comments or
you can pause this video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what RNN
is and proceed further for the same so
what is RNN recurrent neural net so RNN
work on the principle of saving output
on a particular layer and feeding this
back to the input in order to predict
the output of the layer this is how can
convert a feed neural network into a
recurrent neural network RNN the node in
different layers of neural network are
compressed to form a single layer of
recurrent neural network a B and C are
the parameters of neural network now
that you understand what RNN is let's
look at the way why RNN okay so y r n
RNN were created because there are few
issues in the feed forward neural
network cannot handle this equation data
considers only the current input cannot
memorize previously Okay so the solution
of these issues is RNN and RNN can
handle sequential data accepting the
current input data and previously
received input data so RNN can memorize
previous input due to their internal
memory so moving forward let's see how
does RNN networks work okay so the input
layer X takes an input to the neural
network and process it in the passes it
into the middle layer the middle layer
Edge can consist of multiple hidden
layers each with its own activation
function and weight and biases
if you have a neural network where the
various parameters of different hidden
layers are not affected by the previous
layer that is the neural network does
not have the memory then you can use RNN
so the RNN will standardize the
different activation function and
weights and biases so that each hidden
layer has the same parameter then
instead of creating multiple hidden
layers it will create one and loop over
it as many time it is required so moving
forward let's see types of RNN so there
are four types of RNN
one to one
one to many many too many
and many to one
so let's see one to one RNN so this type
of neural network is known as the
vanilla neural network it is used for
General machine learning problem which
has a single input and a single output
now see
one too many RNN this type of neural
network has a single input and multiple
outputs an example of this is an image
captioning now let's see many to one RNN
this RNN take a sequence of input and
generates a single out sentiment
analysis is a good example of this kind
of neural network where a given sentence
can be classified as expressing positive
or negative sentiment and the last one
is many too many RNN this RNN takes a
sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of output machine translation
is the one of the example so moving
forward let's see application of
recurrent neural network first one is
image captioning rnns are used to
caption an image by analyzing the
activities present the second one is
time series prediction and a Time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using RNN
and the third one is natural language
processing text Mining and sentiment
analysis can be carried out using RNN or
NLP natural language processing the
fourth one is machine translation given
an input in one language rnns can be
used to translate the input into
different language as output so now
let's move to the programming part first
we will import some libraries major
libraries for the first we will import
for the data frame so I will write
import
find out
speeding
the second one is import numpy
as NP
so pandas is a software liability
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers a data
structure and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and The
Time series
and this numpy numpy is a library for
the Python programming language adding
support to four large multi-dimensional
array and matrices along with the large
collection of high level mathematical
function to operate on these arrays okay
so for plotting we will import some
libraries like c bond
as
SNS
this is nothing just a short form of we
don't have to write again and again c
bond c bar we can write SNS
so then another one is from
what cloud
word cloud
matplot live
Dot
By plot
as PLT
okay so C bone is a library that uses
matplotlib underneath to plot graphs it
will be used to visualize xandom
distribution and the word cloud is a
visual representation
of words Cloud creators are used to
highlight popular words and phrases
based on frequency and relevance they
provide you with quick and simple visual
insights that can lead to more in-depth
analysis and this matplotlip matplotlib
is a plotting library for the Python
programming language and its numerical
mathematics
extension number it provides an object
oriented API for embedding plots into
applications using general purpose UI
okay like
Tinker double X python qt or gtk
so let's import some
nltk
that's your language toolkit
so
I will write import
nltk
okay from
an ltk
dot stem
import
iser
and from nltk dot Corpus
import
upwards
then
from
and I'll take it or tokenize
code
word
tokenize
so nltk the natural language toolkit or
more commonly analytic is a suit of
libraries and programs for symbolic and
statical natural language processing for
English return and Python programming
language
and this is stop words stop words are
words that are so common they are
basically ignored by
typical tokenizers and this word
tokenized is a function in Python that
splits a given sentence into words using
the analytical liability okay so let's
import some psychic learn
Library so for that I will write from SK
learn
dot model
collection
import
train
test
okay then from sqlan
dot feature
extraction
Dot text import
fid vectorizer
then from
a scale on Dot matrices
Matrix
import
confusion metric
classification
okay
so a second line is a free source
software machine learning library for
Python programming language it features
various classification regression and
clusting algorithms including support
Vector machine learning logistic
regression and many others like random
Forest classifier
and the strain test split method is used
to split our data into train and test
set first we need to divide our data
into features like X and Y labels
and this tfid vectorizer converts a
collection of raw documents into a
matrix of TF or IDF features the fast
tax on what two vectorizer what
embedding python implementation and this
confusion Matrix a confusion Matrix is a
table that is used to define the
performance of a classification
algorithm okay
then we'll import some libraries like
from
scale on
Dot linear model
quote
logistic
regression
than from
no P.M
board
and from
a learn
ER
port
random
or as classifier
okay then from
sqlan Dot name base
port
Bernoulli
is
okay
so everything is correct
you will see while running so logistic
regression estimate the probability of
an event agree such as voted or didn't
vote based on a given data set of the
independent variable
at SVC logistic regression estimate
sorry linear support Vector machine SVC
is an algorithm that attempts to find a
hyperplane to maximize the distance
between classified samples and this is
random for its classifier create a set
of decision trees from a randomly
selected subset of the training set
and this Bernoulli NB or noline air base
is a part of the name based family it is
based on panology distribution and
except only binary values that is 0 or
1.
so let's import some tensorflow so
import
tensorflow
Dot
combat dot V2
and
import
tensorflow
data sets
as tfds
so tensorflow is a free and open source
library for machine learning and
artificial intelligence across a range
of tasks but has a particular focus on
training and inference of deep neural
networks okay that supports warnings
nothing warning
[Music]
warnings
report
Ari
and code strain
airport Beacon
so everything is basic just let's see
the pickle pickle is a python is
primarily used in serializing and
deserializing a python objective
structure okay let's run it
let's see how many other
um
after that we will load the data set and
we will go through data visualization
okay word cloud cannot import name what
cloud okay see c will be Capital here
random Forest
good
okay it's still loading here let's see
okay so loading is done so now let's
load the data set so we'll write data
equals to PD Dot
wait
underscore CSV
data set name
test
all right
so you can find this data set on the
description box below
coding costume Latin
plus two
polarity
okay
ID
command date
comma
very
perhaps your pocket come aware
okay yeah
it seems fine
let me change this first
is using Arena
so here I will write data person
data dot sample
change to one
okay so let me like brief uh tell you
that what we are going to okay
let me brief you like what we will do in
this sentiment analysis using rnm so in
this demo like you will see uh text
processing on Twitter data set and after
that we will perform different machine
learning algorithms on the data such as
logistic reaction random Forest
classifier as we see name based to
classify positive and negative duties
after that I will also build a RNN
recurrent neural network which is the
best fit for such textual sentiment
analysis okay since it's a sequential
data set which is requirement for the
RNN Network
so let's dive into so now
we will see the data data visualization
data set details Target like the
polarity of the tweets zero negative
okay then the date the date of the tweet
and the polarity and the user that were
tweeted than the text okay so I will
write print
data set
if
data
comma ship
okay
wait let me first do like this yeah
so there are 20
or you can say two like rows and six
number of columns okay so it is a huge
data I will you can find this data set
from the description box below so here
let's see the data
and why I use head head is used for like
what's showing
top 10 rows of the data set if you will
use tail instead of head it will show
the last 10 rows of the data set okay
here polarity 0 0 means negative and 4
means positive okay like you can
consider as 0 1
his ID date then query then user then
the text
Okay so
here I will do data
clarity
Dot
okay these are the zero four okay
uniqueness zero means negative and the 4
means positive
replacing the value 4 as 1 for the ease
of understanding what I said to you you
can consider as 0 1 so data
polarity
equals to data
molarity
four two one
okay then data
now you can see zero one zero one zero
one one zero okay
so if you will light only head it will
show the top five rows only
okay
so now let's use one python function and
describe
Dot
type
so as you can see here count is 2 lakh
and the mean of the particular row is
this
and the idea is this standard deviation
minimum value the 25 percent the 50
percent and the 75 percent and the
maximum
okay so let's see the number of positive
versus negative tag this sentence
okay
so here I will write positives
for some data
polarity
data dot polarity
is equals 1
then negatives
data
polarity
data dot polarity
is equal to zero
trend
total
laptop
the data is
dot format
data
dot shape
now I will print
the total length the negative and the
positives okay so number
of
positive
okay
Dot
format
positives
so I will copy
this and paste it here
and here I will do the changes for the
negatives
okay now let's see
so here polarity is not defined
comma
so you as you can see the total length
of the data is too like and the number
of positive sentences is
like 1 lakh 46
and number of negatives okay spelling is
the number of negative text sentences 99
954.
okay so now we have a brief data
so now let's get a word count Pub of
text so for this
I'll be right
around
words
done
length of
or start split
then now let's plot our account
distribution for both positive and
negative
so I will create a bar plot so for that
I would like it
but
round
to data and
text
dot apply
dot count
okay then I will write P positive equals
to data
then
found
data dot polarity
is equals to 1.
and
so let me copy this only
here I will write 0
and
okay then
PLT dot figure
and figure size
question
12 comma six
than PLT
Dot
and PLT dot X label
word count
PRT Dot y11
and frequency
I will write G plus 2
PRT Dot
comma n
color
equal to 0.5
positive
okay then let's make a legend also
location should be
right
Falls
the data word count where it equals to
okay my bad
so as you can see the positive and the
negatives
okay
so these are the like word count
distribution for both positive and
negative okay
so now let's uh
what we can do we can do the get like
get the common words in training data
set
for retaining data set so for that I
will do
from
collections
import
counter
or
words
to
foreign
test
data
text
to line
Dot split
for word
and
words
if length of
word
to them
to
all
voice dot band
dot dot dot lower
where I can write counter
all words
dot most
common then I need 20.
so as you can see these are the most
common word used like in every sentence
the and you for have that I am but just
like this out over all
so these are the most common words like
it used does used like 64 000 times and
like this your is used for a thousand
times
something like that
so now we will do some data Pro data
processing
okay
now let's do the database pressing
so
[Music]
and SNS Dot count plot
data
polarity
okay
these are the negatives and these
positives
there are slight change I guess
that is why it's not looking
so much of different like there's a
slight
with 46 different so that is why it's
looking almost same
okay
so now removing the unnecessary columns
like query user word count
data dot drop
it
query
and word count
X is equals to 1
comma
Place question true
okay
it will be true
so here I will write data
words on this okay my bad
here I will add data dot drop
ID
come on
so
then data dot head
the data see we have only the two the
polarity and the text
okay
so
now
uh let's see the null values
so the
Dot
foreign
okay
so there is no null values so now
converting pandas object
to a string type
for that we have to write
text
let's do data
type
we are
that
yes
I
yeah so now download the stop words and
LDK
done
download
words
once you set
stop words
it's in English
top words
this
these are some
you know stop words
so moving forward let's download
and then take a DOT download
a
okay
dot download
.net
so the pre-processing steps taken are
like lower casting each text is
converted to lowercase then remover of
URLs will do this
my windows okay links starting with HTTP
or St TPS or ww are replaced by like
commas removing usernames removing short
words removing stop words like
limitization is the process
will do of con for the converting award
to its base okay
so for that
what I will do
I'll just copy the whole code for you
will explain you one by one what I've
done
okay
so this is the course for the URL
pattern for removing all the WWE https
and HTTP type of thing and removing
them
and I have used pattern for the lower
casting removing all the URL okay
then removing all the usernames like at
the red and removing punctuations and
stop words
okay like this
so now what we have to do data
p
the processed
tweets
and data
text
dot apply
Lambda
X
process
then tweets
okay
then print
next
tea processing
so it is taking time
and it will be completed it will return
here till text pre-processing is done
okay
as you can see the textbook
pre-processing is done
so now let's check
data Dot
add
done
as you can see see the at the rate and
this slices are gone
okay
so now the text is pre-processed
so now what we will do we will analyze
the data so now we are going to analyze
the preprocess data to get an
understanding of it we will plot word
clouds for positive and negative dutes
from our data set and see which what
occurs the most
okay first we will create for the
negative words or negative tweets you
can see so I will add pld dot figure
and figure size
15 comma 15.
okay then word cloud question
but
cloud
next words
question
two thousand comma
it equals to
comma
height question
and rate
dot join
the data dot polarity
and I will write here polarity
okay equal to zero
again
then
to assessed to its
okay
then here
I have to write
PLT dot show
WC
interpolation
bilinear
okay perhaps you forget to come up here
soon 2000
then come a bit
dot generate
what I can do
let me run now let's see
hope this time it will work
it's still loading
as you can see this is
words okay like today I am and work
don't wish they need much
these are the most negative tweets
okay words from negative tweets you can
say
right
so let's see the positive tweets okay
so the thing will be same
let me copy
paste it here so for this I will do
one
yeah
it will take little bit of time
still loading
like as you can see hate can't
okay
sorry
these are the negative words
okay still loading
so let's wait for like few seconds
now you can see the positive words like
love okay good
LOL
and awesome something like that
okay so these are some
positive words so now let's do the
vectorization and splitting the data
like storing into input variable process
tweets to X and output variable polarity
to y
okay we'll do that
yeah
so x equals to data
says
tweets
values
and by pursue
data
majority
Dot
values
okay
now I will write here print
it's dot shape
paint by dot shape
Okay cool so now what we will do we will
convert text to what frequency Vector
okay TF2 IDF so this is an acronym that
stands for term frequency to inverse
document frequency which are the
components of the resulting scores
assigned to each word okay so term
frequency this summarize how often a
given a word appears within a document
and inverse document frequency this down
scales word that appear a lot across
documents okay so now here we will
convert a collection of raw documents so
a matrix of TF to idea features
okay then I will write
and
because riser
and sub-linear
x equals so
Vector dot with
transform
Ed
okay
and
number of features
comma length
vector
get
their names
the number of feature words are like
okay now we will do like
now let's paint the shape
so now we will do the split uh spread to
train and test so the previous data is
divided into two sets of data training
data and the testing meter so data set
upon which the model would be trained on
contains 80 percent data the test data
is that data set upon which model would
be tested again contains 20 of data so
for that I will write extreme
test
all right train
come on
just
speak
hi
pesticides
equals to 0.20
random
date
plus one zero one
okay
so what I will do I will do the you know
print the shape of extreme y train X
text y test like how many columns are
there rows not column exactly the rows
are there okay
so I'll paste here so see
extreme like this is a total was like 2
lakh
okay
so one lakh 60 000 in training as we
discussed earlier like 80 percent in
training and 20 interesting
okay
so now let's do the model building
OKAY model evaluating functions
so now let's make a model
okay
and first I will do I will write and
then I will explain you the whole okay
so here what I did this will tell you
the accuracy of the model of training
data and the testing data okay then we
will predict the values for test data
set and the evaluation for the data set
then we will compute and plot the
confusion Matrix
okay with the both the categories
negative positives okay group name will
be true negative and the false positive
okay
so
there's nothing that let's run it
so now what we will do we will do first
for the logistic regression so here I
will write LG equals to
logistic
regression
okay then history
equals to LG dot fit
X strain
comma
y train
with an model
evaluate
let's see
this is for the
logistic regression
okay
as you can see the accuracy of the
training data is 83 percent the testing
data is 77 percent
okay
so this is The Confident Matrix the
predictive value like these are the
categories
now let's see for the linear svm for
that I will write svm
plus 2
.
as we see
and svm
dot fit
strain
comma y train
then model
evaluate
of svm
okay
and after that we will do for random
forest and the new base okay then we
will start with the RNN
so as you can see the accuracy of
training data is very pretty good 93
percent and
is 83 percent and testing is less than
regression model let's see
for the random Forest so I will write
here
RF equals to
run down for rest
ifier
30 meters
equals to 20
Criterion equals to
rupee
more than Max
depth equals to 50.
then RF dot fit
strain
comma
y train
and model
evaluate
okay
loading let's see the accuracy how it
will come
after this we will do for the name base
and after that we will move on to the
our main model RNN recurrent neural
networks
still loading
yes it will take little bit of time
so as you can see the confusion Matrix
okay
so training data accuracy 75 percent is
very less so now let's see the last
Model name base
okay so NB equals to
Bernoulli
and B
and B dot fit
strain
comma
y train
okay then model
evaluate
training
8670 so as far
linear SCC has the best
test training accuracy you can say and
the best
testing accuracy is 76 70
76.45
see logistic relation so now let's move
to the our main model RNN so what is RNN
recurrent neural network at the start at
the state of the art algorithm for
sequential data and are used by Apple cd
and Google search voice it is the first
algorithm that remembers its input due
to an internal memory which make it
perfectly suited for machine learning
problem that involve sequential data and
there is one more thing embedding layer
embedding layer is one of the available
layers in Keras this is mainly used in
natural language processing related
applications such as language modeling
but it can also be used with other tasks
that involve neural networks while
dealing with NLP problems we can use
pre-trained word embedding such as globe
alternately we can also train our own
embeddings using Keras emitting layer
STM layer long short term memory
networks usually called lstms I have
made already many videos
you can check it out were introduced by
Sky mender these have widely been used
for speech recognition language
processing sentiment analysis and text
prediction if you are going deep into
lstm we should first understand the need
of lstm which can be explained by the
drawback of practical use of RNA so
let's start with RNA
okay
so here
I will importing some libraries
okay so after that I will write port
get us
version
2.110 okay fine let
so now let's
paint
X test comma
white train
wire test
just to train
test
it
tweets comma data dot polarity
Dot
values
then
test
size
0.2 test size 0.2 means
like 80 and 20 percent
thing
82 training and the
20 percent to
testing
and let's
the model evaluation okay
so I will
these are relu sigmoid all the you know
the layers
so now this Epoch it will run till 5000
like
count will go till 5000 okay see the
5000 and it will go to one to ten so it
will take time so I will get back to you
after this completing this okay
now as you can see uh the Box
then successfully okay
so what should I do but I will get some
space here so now we will see the
positive and negative outcome okay this
is something like testing okay we will
test we will predict
we will give one a sentence and then we
will predict
it is coming right or wrong the accuracy
is giving a right or wrong okay so here
I will write
sequence
request to tokenizer
Dot
text
to
sequences
then I will write this
data science
article
is vast
okay
so here I will write test equals to pad
sequences
and here I will write sequence
comma
max length
plus 2
maxland
then I will write here prediction a
question
model
write model
then we'll write model 12.
2 dot predict
then test
okay
if diction
is greater than 0.5 means 50 percent
then
it should print
positive
okay
else
foreign
again let me run this
sequential object has no
okay spell mistake
the negative because here is the word
worst
it is showing correct now check from the
RNN model so model equals to K res dot
models
dot load
models here we will load RNN model RNN
underscore model
dot SG F5 it is pre-trained model
okay pretend RNN model so sequence
equals to
kenizer
dot text
to sequences
then
I will write here this
this MN
codes
is best
okay
test equals to pad underscore sequences
sequence
thanks and
then prediction
equals to model
dot predict
that test
if prediction is greater than 0.5
and
positive 0.5 means fifty percent more
than 50 percent
else
went negative
and to build load models
being positive because this ml course is
best
so there is no negative word
okay
so what we will do now we will do model
saving loading and prediction okay
so for that uh
I will write import
pickle
y equals to open
vectorizer
because
then
WB
if
here I will add pickle
dot done
dump
better file vector
suppose
okay
so like this I have to write for name
base logitification svm and random
Forest
so
what I will do
right here
okay let's run this
okay
so now what we have to do we have to
predict using saved model okay
what we will do here we will load model
first and we will predict Okay so
first I will write the function name
load
models
and we will load the vectorizer so file
equals to
open
vectorizer
dot pickle
RB
characterizer
because
you can
upload
file
the filing Dot close
now I am loading the logistic regression
model so for that we have to write open
would be
LG equals to
become
file
the file dot closed
then then
riser
LG
okay
and it
yeah
so now we will predict the sentiment so
for that I will write the
predict
divisor
text
okay
so here we will predict the sentiment so
for that
this is
underscore text
equals to
process and score
three
and demands for
sentiment and
text
then
deep
riser
Dot
transform
it says
then sentiment
to model dot predict
so here I will make a list of text with
sentiments so for that I will add data
equals to empty array
then for
text
prediction
and zip
X comma sentiment
dot append
text comma prediction
okay
and we will convert the list into
pointers data frames so for that I will
add t f equals to
80 dot data frame
comma columns
question
next
comma
sentiment
then DF equals to DF Dot replace
comma 1
YouTube
positive
and dear
so at last I will write here if
equals to
um
and here we will loading the model
vectorizer comma LG Plus
the text to classify like what should be
in the list so
next question
here I will like I love machine
learning
foreign
update
the driver
in the command text
then print
DF dot head
okay I love machine learning positive
work is so active positive John I feel
so good negative
okay that is
and
yeah see that's coming okay
this is how you can do
the sentiment analysis using uh rnm
model here we have loaded RNN model so
it is showing right so let's do them as
poses
people
and right here
at
boy
negative okay
RNN model is working so right okay so I
hope you enjoyed this video till later
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to stay updated
and if you want this full code just
comment for the same
and if you have any queries or something
related to Python and machine learning
you can comment down our
expertise will reach you Zone thank you
so much for being here
till then stay safe and keep
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here